So, jetzt habe ich alles was ich brauche und kann jetzt
erstmal meine Form kopieren.
Das geht natürlich über das Menü bearbeiten,
kopieren und dann einfügen bzw.
die entsprechenden Tastaturkürze,
Comment oder Kontroll C und dann Comment oder Kontroll V für
einfügen.
Aber ich habe eine Methode, die noch schneller ist.
Dafür gehe ich auf das Gesamtauswahlwerkzeug,
also den schwarzen Pfeil,
ziehe dann auch über die gesamte Form,
damit ich sicher gehe,
dass jetzt auch Abnäher und Tasche mit dabei sind.
Und jetzt gehe ich auf die Taste Option oder Alt,
je nach System und bewege mich über meine ausgewählte Form
und da sehe ich jetzt da ist kein einfacher Pfeil mehr,
wenn ich Option oder Alt gedrückt halte,
sondern ein Doppelfeil.
Das heißt kopieren.
Jetzt muss ich eigentlich nur auf diese Form draufklicken
und diese rüberziehen und schon habe ich zwei Formen und
habe diese eine Form kopiert.
Jetzt möchte ich diese Form noch
Spiegeln.
Du gehst jetzt in deine Werkzeugleiste und nicht weit
unter dem Rechteck findest du so ein Kreissymbol.
Da gehst du jetzt mal drauf, da ist
so eine kleine Ecke unten rechts und du gehst auf diese
Ecke, dann erscheint unter diesem Kreissymbol das
Spiegelnwerkzeug.
Dort klickst du mit einem Doppelklick drauf.
Normalerweise ist Vertikalspiegel schon voreingestellt und
du gehst nur auf OK und deine Form ist gespiegelt.
Achte darauf, dass du die Form vorher auch ausgewählt hast.
So, wenn du jetzt siehst, es ist alles gespiegelt,
auch Tasche und Abnäher, dann ist alles gut.
Falls das nicht der Fall ist,
dann geh einfach über Ctrl oder Command Z ein paar Schritte
zurück und wiederhole das Ganze.
Und jetzt kannst du auch mal wieder zwischenspeichern.
So, jetzt nimmst du deine rechte Rockhälfte und platzierst
sie genau neben die linke.
Falls dir das etwas schwerfällt, kannst du auch reinzoomen.
Ganz unten in deiner Werkzeugleiste findest du eine Lupe.
Da kannst du draufklicken.
Dann gehst du auf deine Zeichnung.
Es erscheint die Lupe mit einem kleinen Pluszeichen darin.
Das heißt, du kannst reinzoomen.
Wenn du wieder rauszoomen möchtest,
kannst du das über die gleiche Funktion mit
Alt oder Option gedrückt halten
tun.
Wir platzieren jetzt die rechte Rockhälfte neben die linke
und zoomen da jetzt mal rein und gucken,
ob das auch alles stimmig ist,
ob da jetzt auch keine Ecke drin ist und die vordere Mitte
wirklich als eine Linie ineinander übergeht.
Falls das jetzt nicht der Fall sein soll,
können wir das jetzt noch so ein bisschen verändern,
indem wir über das Direktauswahlwerkzeug,
also den weißen Pfeil,
einzelnen Punkt der jeweiligen Rockhälfte etwas anpassen.
So und wenn das jetzt eine Linie ist,
dann können wir diese Formeln eigentlich auch schon
zusammenfügen.
Dafür müssen wir aber erst mal die Mittellinie löschen,
denn die brauchen wir ja nicht mehr.
Um die Mittellinie zu löschen,
gehst du auch mit dem Direktauswahlwerkzeug,
also dem weißen Pfeil,
direkt auf diese
Mittellinie,
du erkennst, dass nur die Linie markiert wurde,
weil deine Punkte ja noch weiß bleiben
Und Dann gehst du einfach auf Entfernen oder Delete.
So jetzt kann es sein,
dass du die Linie von der einen Rockhälfte gelöscht hast,
aber die Linie der anderen Rockhälfte gar nicht
sichtbar ist.
Das liegt daran,
dass in Adobe Illustrator die Voreinstellung so ist,
dass wenn du eine Form zeichnest,
automatisch die Fläche weiß ausgefüllt ist.
Das erkennst du daran,
dass in deiner Werkzeugleiste unten zwei Kästchen sind.
Ein weißes Kästchen und dahinter ist ein schwarzes
Kästchen.
Das weiße Kästchen im Vordergrund,
wenn das ganz ausgefüllt ist, das ist die Fläche,
und das schwarze Kästchen im Hintergrund,
das ist nicht ganz ausgefüllt, das ist der Kontur.
Und jetzt ist diese Fläche meistens weiß voreingestellt.
Wenn du nicht möchtest dass diese Fläche farbig gefüllt ist,
kannst du unter diesen beiden Kästchen ganz rechts auf
dieses weiße Kästchen mit dem roten Strich gehen.
Das heißt, die Fläche ist transparent.
Also wähl jetzt deine Rockhälfte aus und geh auf dieses
Kästchen was durchgestrichen ist, und du wirst sehen,
die Mittellinie wird sichtbar werden.
Jetzt kannst du wieder über das Direktauswahlwerkzeug deine
Mittellinie anklicken und löschen.
Jetzt kannst du eigentlich deinen Rock schon zusammenfügen,
geh jetzt auf dein Auswahlwerkzeug und ziehe über die beiden
Rockformen drüber an der Stelle,
wo du sie zusammenfügen möchtest,
und dann klickst du auf rechtsklick auf zusammenfügen.
Das Ganze wiederholst du auch noch mal am Saumen.
So jetzt hast du die Form oben und unten zusammengefügt,
und wenn du jetzt heranzoomst mit der Lupe,
dann wirst du erkennen, dass sich ja zwei Punkte auf dieser
Linie befinden.
Und ich hatte dir ja schon mal gesagt,
es ist immer ganz günstig,
so wenig Punkte wie möglich zu haben,
um dann später deine Linie auch verändern zu können und neue
Zeichnungen anzulegen mit dieser Zeichnung als Grundlage.
Daher würde ich dir empfehlen,
jetzt diesen einen Punkt zu löschen.
Das geht aber nicht ganz so einfach,
also nicht einfach mit dem Direktauswahlwerkzeug.
Wir benutzen hierzu die Zeichenfeder,
und zwar den Ankerpunkt löschen innerhalb dieses Werkzeugs.
Geh also auf die Zeichenfeder, da findest du unten rechts
so einen kleinen Teil, klick da drauf.
Vorher hast du deine Form ausgewählt,
und jetzt gehst du mit diesem Ankerpunkt löschen Werkzeug
auf den Punkt, den du löschen möchtest.
Klickst da drauf und schon ist er weg und deine Form bleibt
aber noch erhalten.
Als nächstes möchte ich noch den Bund zeichnen.
Den Bund kannst du auch am Anfang zeichnen,
zusammen mit der einen Rockhälfte und dann kopieren und
spiegeln, wie wir das gerade gemacht haben.
Ich zeichne den Bund aber meistens in einem Stück.
Also positionierst du dich jetzt auf der Seitenlinie,
auf die Höhe, wo dein Bund sein soll,
und setzt hier deinen ersten Punkt.
Dann gehst du rüber zur anderen Seite.
Du siehst, es gibt hier ein paar Hilfslinien,
die helfen dir, dich zu orientieren,
damit du die Höhe deines Punktes auf der anderen Seite auch
wieder findest.
Also ziehst du da jetzt rüber zur anderen Seite,
lässt aber deine Zeichenfeder gedrückt,
damit du eine schöne geschwungene Kurve zeichnen kannst.
Achte hier darauf dass die Tangente in der Mitte ankommt,
damit diese Kurve auch wirklich von der einen zur anderen
Seite harmonisch ausfällt.
Jetzt lässt du los und klickst wieder auf deinen Punkt,
um frei weiterzeichnen zu können.
Dann gehst du ganz gerade nach unten und setzt deinen
nächsten Punkt.
Dann gehst du wieder rüber zur anderen Seite und achtest
wieder darauf, dass deine Tangente bis zur Mitte
ankommt,
damit diese Kurve auch wieder parallel zu der anderen Kurve
harmonisch verläuft.
Jetzt setzt du deinen Punkt auf der anderen Seite und dann
kommst du wieder zurück zum Ausgangspunkt und schließt
die Form.
Nochmal zur Erinnerung, hier ist ein kleiner Kreis zu sehen,
das heißt, deine Form wird jetzt geschlossen.
So und vielleicht kennst du das ja aus der
Schnittkonstruktion schon.
Die vordere Mitte ist etwas tiefer als die hintere
Mitte, deswegen haben wir jetzt eigentlich auch eine Form,
die nach unten geschwungen ist.
Das hat zur Folge,
dass man jetzt in der technischen Zeichnung das Hinterteil
von dem Rock auch sehen würde und deswegen werden wir dieses
Hinterteil auch einzeichnen.
Das Hinterteil des Rockes ist im Gegensatz zum Vorderteil
dann nach oben geschwungen,
denn da brauchen wir etwas Höhe für unser Gesäß.
Also positionierst dich jetzt auf der Höhe von deinem Bund,
um das Rückteil zu zeichnen.
Also ich klicke jetzt hier drauf und ziehe jetzt zur anderen
Seite und gestalte eine Kurve,
die nach oben geschwungen ist.
Jetzt hast du dein Rückteil gezeichnet.
Oftmals gibt es aber im Bund auch noch mal eine Absteppung
und die können wir jetzt auch noch einzeichnen.
Eigentlich ist das eine Linie,
die jetzt parallel zu dieser Linie verläuft,
die du schon gezeichnet hast.
Du könntest also diese Linie einfach kopieren,
indem du auf das Auswahlwerkzeug gehst und dann wieder über
Option Alt dich darauf positionierst und wenn du den
Doppelfeil siehst,
die Linie einfach nach unten ziehst und dann ist
sie kopiert.
Oder du zeichnest einfach parallel zu deiner ersten Linie
mit dem Zeichenwerkzeug eine zweite.
So eine Absteppung ist aber meistens auch
so dass sie nicht durchgängig gezeichnet wird,
sondern als gestrichelte Linie.
Dazu gehst du über Eigenschaften Kontur,
klickst darauf und kannst jetzt hier
gestrichelte Linie ankreuzen.
Die Voreinstellung ist meistens zwölf Punkt,
was viel zu groß ist.
Das ändern wir jetzt hier auf zwei Punkt und die Lücke auch
auf zwei Punkt und dann haben wir eine schöne
gestrichelte Linie.
Achte aber darauf,
dass hier die Punktstärke auch wieder reduziert ist.
Also ich gehe hier meistens dann auch auf 0,5 Punkt und habe
so eine schöne Absteppung.
So, jetzt ist mein Vorderteil vollständig.